hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
a prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous video you could
see us hooking up electricity
which is quite an important piece of
infrastructure to set up our land
and in today's video we're going to look
into our water because up until now
we've always been using jerry cans which
we refill
here in this local little water tap
which is great
but temperatures are rising more people
are coming so this is getting quite
difficult to achieve and it's also just
a short-term solution so we're going to
look into something more proper in this
video
to see what our water options are and
first we're going to explore the
borehole
and we're going to look for a water tank
to store the water we're gonna pump up
i think this is also the fastest water
tap in the world
[Music]
we're gonna check out a water tank for
our borehole system and this guy is
selling some
second-hand metal ones let's see
[Applause]
so it got suddenly quite rainy and we
went into his office
a little wooden box in the corner of his
workspace the place to discuss business
he was actually more making funny
drawings of a water tank and this guy
buys old tanks and refurbishes them into
his workspace
so he went over some details like which
material and size he recommends and how
to install it
and the first thing he mentioned is
deciding on a size
and he suggested to go big
so this is a 20 000 liter tank
it's big all right so this man has a lot
of
water tanks kind of a funny setting in
his whole landscape he has tanks
everywhere
so for a water tank you basically have a
few options the cheapest one is a
plastic one
or pvc but obviously it doesn't last as
long
it's not super well nice for the
environment and he also had a funny
story that
as the other day he had a hunter that
shot it
and there was a hole in the water tank
so he it's not a fan
then you also have metal tanks which are
great for robust and durable
but for drinking water not really ideal
the very cool ones are from stainless
which
obviously lasts longer they don't rust
more expensive
and but has a few cool ones that are
from old breweries
and where they make wine and store it so
he buys them
cleans them up and then he turns them
into water tanks
and this one right here is a 16 000
liter
which seems a good size for us it's
probably too big
for sure in the beginning when we're not
with many people yet
however it's also super good for us to
have a surplus of water because it's
kind of a fire
area where we are so having water in the
middle of summer is always kind of a
safe backup
and he actually has a few options of
different tanks
and there are different thicknesses and
this one is the thickest one
it's five millimeter it's quite thick
and the other ones are two millimeters
but this one would last longer and it
also keeps the water
nice and cold in the summer times so he
was highly recommending
to get this one and but obviously a bit
more expensive and also
logistically you need a bigger crane and
stuff to get it
so we're probably going to go for the 16
000 liter seems like a good option
and now we still have to figure out how
to actually get it on the land
and making sure all the connections and
hoses fit
but uh yeah seems like a very cool tank
and this water tank right here was empty
and not mounted to the floor and got
blown away by the wind
so now it's there all right so now we're
back in base camp
and we're gonna have a look into where
we would actually mount this big water
tank on the land
what's a good location for it so we're
thinking of having it
uphill because then we can use gravity
to make the water come down
so we would also need to drill the hole
there so we're going to have a walk over
the road
to see if we can actually access that
part of the hill
because in the end also the truck needs
to go there to deliver the water tank
and to drill the hole so let's have a
look
so there's actually the top of the hill
we have to go so we could go straight up
here
but we actually need to find a path wide
enough where the truck can go
which is not there so we need to walk
around quite a bit
and i think on google map from satellite
view i saw a little
road that you can access it by truck but
no idea how clear it is and how
overgrown
it is by now so yeah we're gonna walk a
bit around and check it out
so as you can see the road here is
pretty rough
even though a few months ago they
actually smoothened it all up and they
put this gravel on top
to make sure the shipping containers
would come but by now
some rain has fallen and already broke
the road again
sitting on a hole in the road
i don't know why
[Applause]
this for you youtube
so now we reach the ecolyptus area where
it's really
basically a farm full of eucalyptus tree
where they're growing them
i'm still kind of impressed actually how
much you see this in this area of
portugal
pretty sure at some point we would do a
more in-depth video about it
yeah we have some pretty close to our
land
so here we have the main road and
somewhere here
it should be a side
road
which i think is here actually so this
should be the road
that the truck can access might need
some clearing up
but let's see if we can go all the way
[Applause]
so we're now at the top of the hill
got more grassy here for some reason and
our land is
right there on that side
and how you can recognize it around here
is how they divide the land and see the
borders
is you have these markations here so for
instance this means it's the edge of our
land
so now i'm in our land and this is
neighbor land
so first we're going to check a little
bit where actually the border of our
land is
and then we're going to see what would
be a good surface area
where we could possibly drill and put
the water tank so here we have another
markation
which goes straight to the other line we
just saw so the land is
here and that is neighborland again so
this is another
landmark it's inside this rock so this
caved out area means it's a landmark
and this is actually how they used to do
it before they would put concrete poles
into the soil
they use things that are already there
like big stones that you don't really
move
so the land goes from the pole uh there
to here
and then down there that's the borders
of the land
and i think what would actually be a
good area is there
where it's flat enough to put the water
tank so we're gonna have a look there
i mean it isn't really too exciting to
show on this video
but uh this seems like the place where
we have the road right there so the
truck would be able to come
and uh flat enough to install the pump
the borehole and the water tank so
this area here would then probably need
to be cleared out
so all the trucks and machinery can
access
and then we could drill and install it
right here so to briefly explain how a
borehole works
it's a big truck would come they drill a
hole into the earth
depending on where they estimate the
water would be the average drilling
in this area is between 60 and 110
meters deep
because it depends a bit if you're on a
hill or in a wet area or in a dry area
um so it's just a like 15 centimeter
diameter tube going all the way down
from there you would install a pump so
the pump would pump the water from down
there
up and the pump can use gasoline
or you connect it to the grit in our
case we would hook it up to a few solar
panels here
so it's autonomous and we can just
install it anywhere
from there you would pump the water
either straight to where you want to
have it
but it's more effective to have a big
water tank
in between there because the water tank
make sure you always have water even if
it's
dryer or you need more than you can pump
and it's also good in case
backup here in case there is a fire so
we can distribute the water on the land
even if electricity would be dead and
burnt
up here you can see the view and
back there now it's a bit foggy so i'm
not sure if you see it it's the highest
mountain of portugal
and in the winter you see the snow on
there
so it's it's good for the water tank and
has a nice view
to look into
okay so we got quite excited about the
borehole probably because we love the
big tanks from the guy
however we had some second thoughts
mainly because to set up base camp we
wanted to keep things simple
don't be too invasive to the land but
make sure we take our time to observe
before we do big actions and this became
quite a big operation
so time to zoom out and look at our
water options
right so we basically have three options
to get water here
one is the borehole second is getting
water from a spring
third is to get water from rain
collection the first one
well you drill a hole in the earth you
take water from very deep
you put a big water tank and you're good
to go the upsides you have fresh water
you have a big water reservoir high on
the land and probably also pretty clean
water because it comes from deep so
no filtering needed downsides it's a big
operation
in our case it was up the hill so we
still need quite some pipes to go
down around 200 meters the costs are
around
six thousand for the pump and tubes
three thousand for drilling and 5000 for
a water tank
and we're not 100 sure yet which
location is the best
because it depends a bit on where we
settle in the future
second option is we get a water from a
well this is somewhat similar to a
borehole
but instead of drilling 60 meters deep
you find an area in the land where the
water is closer to the surface
and you could probably hear be around
four to six meters
and the upsides is it's an easier
operation the neighbors recommend this
one
and we could do this quite close to the
base camp downside is the water can be
less clean because it's not coming from
that deep
it's not 100 percent guaranteed water
and dry months
you still need to drill into the earth
so some big machinery is required
and it's not higher than where we are at
the base camp so we need to find a way
to pump it or use a pressure tank to
make sure we have pressure on our tubes
the cost would be around 800 euros to
dig the well
and around 5000 for the pump system and
filter
and the third option is rainwater
collection i guess this kind of speaks
for itself but you would basically
on the surface of the land gather your
rainwater
and you find a way to filter it so you
can use it and the upside is there's
plenty of rain around here
and it's not invasive at all you don't
need to dig
or drill you just take the water that
falls from the sky
the downside is it still requires some
filtering we don't really have any big
surfaces yet so we'd really need to
build a structure to gather all the
water
and in dry periods it can be hard to
keep your water levels up or the water
would get very old as it's not flowing
or coming in
so these are kind of the options around
here and after a good night's sleep
we came up with an idea which is to use
an old abandoned well
right next to us from our neighboring
land
okay so let me show you that well so
here is base camp
freeta is currently filming from on top
of the workspace container
here we have a road
and here we have neighboring land and
right
here is a well
i'm standing on top of it right now
so it's actually super close to base
camp
which would be quite an easy way to get
rather right here
but let's have a closer look at this
thing so i'm now sitting on the top of
the lid
from the well so this is the lid here's
a hook so you can lift it up if you're
strong enough
and what is usually underneath is rings
of concrete that are dick into the soil
until they reach the water level so if
you would open up this lid
you should find water on the bottom of
it but generally they keep these things
closed to make sure the well
stays clean and we actually notice there
at the end you have
an open well where the excess water the
overflow from this well flows into so
you can actually take it out
so let's have a look at that
so over here you have the well it's a
bit hard to see
probably with all the bushes so let me
explain so there's a tunnel right there
which goes to the well we just saw
and then the water flows here and here
are two concrete walls
and that makes sure it doesn't collapse
i actually see some water flowing here
right now
and then it flows down there to that
compartment
where the water accumulates so you can
take it out to use it
and it's actually a good thing that i do
see the water flowing which means the
well is still
alive and clean that it provides water
so as you can see the well is pretty
overgrown and bushy
but it seems to be usable but that would
also be the first thing we would do to
actually ask the neighbor if we could
even use it
because well it's there well and but in
exchange we would clean it
and we probably don't really need to
clean all of this but mainly the big
well we saw in the beginning the one
close to base camp
because from that well we would pump the
water up probably with a
pressure tank to make sure we have
enough pressure on
all our tubes perhaps a filter installed
but before we go into all of that we
first need to check if you can actually
use it
with the neighbor and i think generally
we do feel better
using this well because drilling a ball
is kind of invasive to the land you also
need to really decide
where you want to put this water tank
and to be honest at that point we're not
really sure yet
because we're still observing the land
researching and where we would actually
build little pieces of infrastructure
and where the water would need to be
so it's already quite a thing to set up
like
the water that massive tank up there so
this would be in a way a much smoother
and less invasive action because
the thing is already here it's abandoned
it's nice to clean it up
it's quite next to the base camp so yeah
this one feels
uh a bit like a smaller scale solution
but in a way good enough for us to get
started
all right so that was it for this video
thanks for watching
if you want to see what we're going to
do next with all the water make sure to
subscribe
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
thanks for watching see you in the next
video i'm not gonna jump in
it's not gonna happen